[Music]
[Applause]
it's always a better day when i see
chris haynes senior nba insider for
yahoo sports chris we just stumbled upon
something we were talking during the
commercial break the greatest most
talented most talented um how about most
skilled duo
of all time
most skilled where would kd and kyrie
rank on your list
that's a good question dp and thanks for
having me back man uh we talking about
the best skill duo
it's hard to look
anywhere else aside from kd and kyrie
because those guys you know when you
talk about one-on-one isolation
basketball being able to get their own
shot create off the dribble post
whatever those two can do it all so even
if you're talking about michael jordan
scotty pippen i don't know
even lebron kyrie that duo lebron dwyane
wade
skill
it would be hard for me to argue against
kd and kyrie uh what if uh well curry
and kd
playing together at golden state um
magic and kareem from a skill position
no i'm still i'm still rocking with with
katie and kyrie i mean steph as great as
steph is like he can't get his own
basket like kyrie can so that's why we
talk about skill and that's and that's
different you know you talking about
what's the best duo then we can have a
different conversation but when you're
talking skill set you know just pure
putting the ball on the ground being
able to do whatever you want to do with
it like nobody can do
what kd and kyrie can do but best duo
that's a different conversation any
problem with how minnesota's celebrated
last night beating
i was a little surprised but then you
know you remember you know they haven't
been in the playoffs in a while i forgot
the drought that
they broke getting to the postseason um
2004 2000 2004. so yeah i'll give i'll
give it to him this is a this is a
relatively young team too so i i've
given them that i don't think anybody
expected minnesota to make this leap
this year so i i'll you know i didn't
really have a problem with it i was
surprised but you know then pat bev
going against his former team you know
he's going to bring all the antics and
the emotions into the to the game so
it was fun i'm looking forward to it i
actually that's that's my assignment for
tnt
on the sidelines for the first round i
got that minnesota memphis series okay
so i'm looking forward to it uh what
what's your assessment of memphis
they're a really fun team to watch um
they play really hard i i had john moran
on my podcast um
a couple days ago it's gonna drop
sometime this week but you know they
it's a college atmosphere that's the
best way i would explain it you know you
see after the games when somebody would
talk to the i guess the star player of
that game and then you see the whole
team just hugging around just celebrate
like it's a really tight-knit group and
they're fun to watch and you know john
morant you know he's he's a rising star
in his league so
i'm i'm interested and looking forward
to seeing if that style of play what
they've been able to do in the regular
season is going to be able to translate
into the postseason josh says they're
ready so we'll see but they had a great
record without john the lineup and i
said well there's two ways to look at
this that maybe he's that'll hurt his
mvp chances but also
it should make you focus on the talent
that memphis has because it's not just
ja morant and if you watch them they
have a deep team uh
both ends they play hard
and did jaw talk up did you address the
team's success without him in the lineup
yeah he said that they're a deep team
and he he credited desmond baines who he
said who he believes should win the most
improved player uh award he also said he
should be in the running as well because
i asked him about that like does a star
player uh somebody who we consider to be
a budding star should they be in the you
know in the running for most improved he
said yeah because i feel like i did
improve from last year but he said he
gives that honor desmond bane but look
dylan brooks one of the best two-way
players we have in this game who has an
edge and i'm looking forward to seeing
dylan brooks patrick beverly because i
think it's going to be a appointed two
where those two are going to get into it
but it's a deep team and not not a lot
of household names but they're really
well coached by coach jenkins and so i'm
like i said i'm interested in seeing if
they have that poise they have that
poise because that's what's going to get
you through come playoff time talking to
chris haynes senior nba insider yahoo
sports he is a sideline reporter for tnt
as well
where do the lakers go from here
starting with the coach that they bring
in
vp that's a good question you know
obviously you know
rob palinka said in his ex in the exit
interview that they want a coach that
has a voice meaning they want somebody
who's going to command the respect of
lebron james and anthony davis and i've
been covering lebron james for nearly a
decade i was the beat rider in cleveland
when he was there and uh i remember when
uh
when they hired david black
and david black came with all these
accolades over there overseas and
he felt like that would translate over
here as far as respect
and i saw the way lebron
looked at david black and how he was
treated with that team so it's going to
take a figure like that who has some
cachet now who's out there i think it
ultimately is going to depend dp on
some of the teams that still left what
do they do meaning philadelphia 76ers
do they sputter in the playoffs and if
they do is doc river's job on the line
same situation with utah jazz quinn
snyder so it's going to take i think if
they're going to have to wait until the
field plays itself out to see ultimately
the candidates that they really do have
and then somebody i gotta throw in mark
jackson i think he deserves a shot i
think he'll be somebody that would be
looked at and evaluated also somebody
they can look at in-house phil handy who
is people look at him as one of the best
or obvious arguably the best skill
development coach but he wants to be a
head coach in this league he's somebody
who i've seen
go at cuss out
lebron james anthony davis he has the
respect that
that that on that duo so you know they
can go a multitude of ways but
ultimately man it's going to take
somebody to come has cashed from day one
because they're trying to win a
championship now but when is lebron
respected his coach
tp don't throw that out there dp don't
do that he's respecting his co look he
respected he respected ty lue for sure
and if we want to look at if we want to
look at
some blunders we could talk about
blunders that the liquors made this past
off season well let's talk about the
blunder and not bringing over tai lu
because that would have been the
ultimate god the ultimate candidate they
brought it they tried to hire ty lue but
they wanted to give him the same
contract as luke walton well ty lue is a
championship coach you can't do that
that's disrespectful
and they didn't allow tyra tyron liu to
hire his full staff which is a no-no
when you're trying to bring in a
top-level coach and so we see what ty
lue was doing with the clipper so that
would have been
that would have been the prime target
right there but they they messed that up
i i love monty williams i think that you
know when coaches turn down the lakers
that that to me is interesting and you
know you're gonna walk into
year 20 for lebron you got russell
westbrook
and you're not sure what you have with
anthony davis kind of
night in night out weekend week out
month in month out how attractive is
that laker job well i would say this
obviously it's it's a prime situation
for any coach to take over
but monty williams ain't taking that job
that is too much going on right now and
i know the lakers want to dismiss these
past couple of weeks how things were
handled how
frank vogel was
you know initially fired on twitter
before he got the official word like so
nobody wants to go and that's go into
that situation nobody was dying to get
to that situation but it is a prime
destination with marquee players and so
with that being said monty williams i i
don't see that at all i think that would
be a pipe dream um but there there will
be suitors right there and you mentioned
russell westbrook vp i don't know if
he's seen the his exit interview but
he went in choosing violence you know he
he set the place on fire before he
walked out you know you see those
he's in denial chris he's in denial
that that may be the case dp but he was
like i'm gonna go out in denial but
chris he said hey i didn't get a chance
to really be myself there he played in
more games played in more minutes than
anybody on the lakers team
like what did you want to show us
besides air balls and turnovers
uh
i mean come on
dp i'm not condoning
what he said
i'm not approving it all i'm saying is
he went in there with an agenda that i'm
setting the place on fire and i'm
walking away you know you see those
movies scene where you set something on
fire and you kind of walk away in slow
mo with the ashes and everything
in the back that's what russ did yeah
but where's he going though
chris he's not going anywhere is he
he'll hill house he'll well look
i can't see a scenario he's going to opt
in for 47 million dollars and then the
lakers have a big decision to make do
you trade him which you you will be able
to do so you might not get the best deal
back in return but you can trade them
also they still have that stretch
provision where they can wave and
stretch your salary over a period of
years so they have options like look we
didn't think russ was coming back
even before that exit interview now that
he let the light lift the place on fire
come on now just don't see it happen
yeah but it was really about him and
frank vogel not connecting and i'm sure
vogel didn't want russell westbrook but
he had to take him because see i just
don't know how much power lebron has he
either has a lot or he doesn't have any
because he's being portrayed as well he
wanted russ and uh they so they decided
to bring in russ if
if he wanted ty lue
then they should have gotten ty lue for
him
yeah i agree with you there but what i
kind of disagree with you or partially
disagree with you on dp is that
it was a frank vogel thing because i
think if you look at his his responses
his answer i'm talking about westbrook
like people say you know he didn't take
accountability he was still like it
wasn't my fault it wasn't my problem and
so if you still have that mindset that's
going to carry on with any other coach
because you're still gonna if he comes
back he's still gonna be the third
option and he just did not perform well
so i think it goes deeper than him and
frank vogel i think him going on there
saying that look i didn't have a fair
chance i wasn't able to be myself i
think that's a deeper issue than the
frank vogel issue well i and i don't
know if the media said well what is
yourself
is it the guy was in washington with the
wizards is it the guy who was in houston
is it the guy who still thinks he can
play like he did in oklahoma city
i that's why i think russ is in denial
he's 34 he's not going to change and
it's not like
kevin love with the cavaliers as the
third person or chris bosh with the heat
is the third person i don't think russ
goes yeah i'm the third person i don't
think he plays that way
yeah i think what what he wants is to
have control of the ball he wants to be
able to play himself which means like
get the rebound go up and make a play
make plays happen now the problem with
that is if you look at the first couple
of months of the season they kind of
allowed russ to
try to play his way but the turnovers
kept mounting and you know we saw
the shot selections and then then he
started getting taken off the ball and
so that that's that's when things kind
of went south right there so they tried
it i don't think russ felt like they
gave it a long enough shot
talking to chris haynes senior nba
insider for yahoo sports uh steph curry
good to go
i think i think he i think he'll give it
a go dp i think he'll give it a go he's
been progressing well i talked to people
with the warriors um they liked how he
looked up to this point hasn't done
anything rigorous but
uh you know if you know he's going he uh
it'll be hard for me to imagine game one
him not suiting up for the warriors in
the playoffs i think he'll be able to go
and luca with a calf muscle is is a
little less tricky yeah that's a little
trickier right there obviously i can't
get a good read on that there's people
in the organization that don't have a
good read on that so it's really going
to be
probably a game time decision with him
always great to talk to you chris uh
have fun in the playoffs
dp you take care brother that's chris
haynes